selena and chef season four is dropping
and where was this season filmed the
house from hannah montana season four
also known as hannah montana forever if
you see a picture of the house you can
hear the house say
she always lived on the beach you know
she was a spoiled brat
um
and she was extremely privileged and she
like it's literally like nepo baby
nepotism at its finest she was also like
working in the bread earner in her
family not really not us literally
canceling out of montana she came from
like an extremely privileged background
like she wouldn't have gotten the
opportunities that she got if it weren't
for her dad billy ray stewart um yeah
she's definitely a nepo baby but not
without talent i'm not saying that she's
not good i'm just saying like what about
you know all the doors that were opened
for her yeah and doors that weren't open
for others again i think that's kind of
a conversation a piece of the
conversation that's missing when
dissecting hannah montana